wow talk about coming out swinging in
your directorial debut this is
this is the one to watch this weekend
I'm just saying
[Music]
so talk to me is an a24 indie horror
reflect I saw the trailer some time ago
never saw the trailer again but I saw
the trailer I was like that actually
looks pretty awesome time goes on forgot
all about it and people in the comment
section of my last review were like you
should totally watch talk to me that
that's the one you should be watching I
was like oh what's that oh that movie
yeah that trailer looked great and talk
to me there's this creepy porcelain
hands you shake the hand you say talk to
me a spirit will appear the spirit can
latch on to you if they do it for less
than 90 seconds hey it's fun times more
than 90 seconds you might just be
haunted forever which actually it's
cooler than it sounded just now when I
was hearing myself talk about it I was
like that just sounds like every horror
movie ever haunted object people mess
around with the haunted object now
something is latched on to the folks
messing around with the haunted object
right we've seen that how many times
it's kind of what I love about this
though it shows what a familiar sounding
concept can be in the right hands
elevated with its own Spin and it feels
new without over complicating it that's
another thing I love the fact that the
object it could be any object for this
film it's a hand the handshake is a
universal friendly greeting for most
folks don't go very wrong in here
there's something simple yet brilliant
about that now the director is Danny and
Michael Filippo is their feature film
directorial debut and they have a
YouTube channel they're YouTubers I mean
among other things you look at the IMDb
they are listed as working as crew
behind the camera on some other projects
TV shows and films they also made short
films on their YouTube channel it's just
what a great story it's actually kind of
incredible work in the industry behind
the camera get the experience make short
films on your YouTube channel gain the
experience gain the skills and when
you've gained all the skill points in
this RPG known as life turn them all in
crush it in your directorial debut and
that's exactly what they did because if
you look at their YouTube channel and
you hear these guys are going to make a
feature film you would be forgiven if
you thought yeah it's going to be a
super high octane action flick it's not
this is a very deliberate early paced
amazingly creepy horror films the pacing
in this movie is great it doesn't Rush
the tension building but also it starts
out with this scene that just makes you
like oh my God it just sticks with you
kind of like a reverse babysitter from
Hell sitting with you while you're
watching the plot build like it's
whispering in your ear all like don't
worry
it's not going to be
a bill the cast is a group of young very
talented generally Unknown People by me
the ones I did know Miranda Otto who
played Aeon in The Lord of the Rings
movies she plays the mom I thought she
was fantastic she had a couple of
moments of interaction that made me
chuckle but it didn't overtly look like
they were just trying to interject humor
into this film it didn't feel out of
place how many times we've seen that
these days it's like movies are like
yeah but we gotta have funny things to
just feel out of place it was never like
that but then when it gets real it
absolutely gets real she's very dramatic
about it it just all worked also Zoe
tarakis who I personally knew from the
Wentworth series was also really good in
here like everybody does a great job but
Sophie Wilde is the star of this film
the main character being tormented by
Spirits possessed by Spirits I thought
she was phenomenal human vulnerable and
scary all at the same time you know when
she's the one being scary don't [__]
around with ghosts they can be dicks but
how is the horror in the film yes the
horror is very effective you have visual
horror some of these ghosts are actually
pretty horrific looking there are a
couple of gross out moments which I
usually don't like but in most movies
the gross out moments like everything
else tries too hard in this movie I felt
the gross out moments were in context of
the world that we're dealing with here
as best I can say it what you're dealing
with there's one scene in particular I'm
like that's nasty
but that would happen but this movie
deals with the best of horror which for
me is the anxiety you know it's that
proverbial guitar string tightening in
the room the tension that just doesn't
go away it gives you some solid haunting
creep Factor but better than most also
illustrates the state of mental hell and
torment that situation would be in terms
of unbridled fright Factor this is the
most effectively
scary or unsettling horror movie I've
seen in a very long time guys in the end
I genuinely hope this movie is number
one in the box office this weekend a
couple more days of Word of Mouth I hope
it gets there because it genuinely
deserves it and if not this weekend hey
as we've seen recently Word of Mouth can
carry a film onward and upward I hope it
gets there if someone had told me that
this film was actually directed by a
very seasoned horror director I would
have believed it it's that well executed
and something that feels fresh new and
elevated in the horror movie genre it's
one of my favorites of the Year
absolutely not going to draw this out
any longer talk to me is
awesome tacular
all right so talk to me have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to say more